good to see so many of you back I know
it has been an exhausting week for those
of you who were freshmen I know they've
had you in workshops every hour of every
day I talked to Abby the other day and
she said I said when can we schedule
something and she said after twelve
thirty at night or during dinner and I
thought we don't want to do either one
of those but you're probably I don't
know maybe there's still all that
enthusiasm there's still all that hope
there's all that energy but maybe you're
facing the possibility that human life
will continue at Yale that maybe there
might be problems here maybe that this
place won't be perfect maybe there might
be people you might not get along with
what happened to that joy of the first
day when everybody was your friend what
happened to all those possibilities what
happened to that possibility that you
would completely reinvent yourself in
this new place and that all the problems
you'd ever have in your life we're back
there in the past but slowly real life
creeps it back in we all want to be seen
as good people at least I think most of
us I can look in the back peel maybe
maybe there's somebody back there that
does not want to be seen as a good
person everybody I know here wants to be
seen as a good person and even those who
enjoy being bad some of the time there
are a few there are a few people yell
who enjoy being bad some of the time
still they want the important people in
their lives their parents their
professors their friends to think that
they're good people right even if you're
a bad person you want the people close
to you to think you're good if they were
to die they would not want people to
come to their funeral and laugh and
celebrate at the end of such a nasty
person nobody I know wants that
everybody wants to be seen as good and
yet our scriptures today confront us
with the fact that we do bad
even good people do bad things usually
only in times of extreme stress or
possibly intoxication but still good
people cheat by abuse others and abuse
themselves good people do selfish stupid
things there's nothing worse than waking
up in the morning and realizing that you
are not the nice person that you thought
you were everybody has a moment in their
life where they wake up and they're
impression of themselves is shattered by
something small or something big usually
they did to somebody else they cheated
on an exam they joined in when someone
weaker was ridiculed or abused they cut
corners in some way they lied to someone
that loves them sometimes when someone
feels very bad about what they've done
they come to see me or their priest or
their pastor thinking so that somehow
there pastor knows something about
goodness that they don't of course this
always surprises the pants off the
pastor who is very much aware of his or
her own moral failings but we are seen
as experts but this is an issue not just
for professional religious people this
is an issue for all of us and I think it
is in many ways the issue for our time
what does it mean to be good what does
it mean to be moral what does it mean to
do the right thing we spend a lot of
time thinking about a lot of our
scriptures was devoted to it I remember
yang Lee one of our student deacons last
year always said that part of our
church's mission at Yale should be to
provide a moral context in the midst of
the pressure and careerism of Yale and
certainly morality is put in danger by
that pressure and careerism success at
all
what we try and do is provide a context
around that today all of our Bible texts
speak about doing good and doing bad I
don't know why we get this the second
week of the semester you know they
should give us a couple more days of
just good news and Jesus and feeling
happy but we go straight to sin Moses
reminds the people Israel that their God
has given them this incredible legacy
this beautiful and just set of laws to
govern their lives James teaches his
church that it's not enough to hear
God's teaching one must do the word we
must live the law not just believe in it
and Jesus in mark 7 in a truly
remarkable fashion just goes off on the
Pharisees and the scribes about what
kind of behavior makes a person good the
scribes and the Pharisees come to him
with this very simple question about why
his group doesn't wash their hands
before they eat sounds so easy just say
yes or no just say why or why not and
Jesus goes nuts he throws Isaiah at them
and says they've forgotten gone and
replaced God with their own traditions
and all this it sounded just like
politics this week you know had nothing
to do with any facts or what anybody
ever said and will be the same next week
you know it's just you know you're a
horrible person and you need to be
condemned and Jesus does this to the
Pharisees but there's something going on
and I think it's something we don't talk
about nearly often enough about what is
good not in the sense of if you disagree
with me about what is good you're bad
but in the sense of how do I figure out
for myself in a complicated world what
is good and the issue for Jesus seems to
be hypocrisy I think we have music in
the background I was smelling meat
cooking earlier you can tell it's the
undergrad International Festival out
there saying you believe something but
do something else hypocrisy it's a
dangerous word for religious people to
use because often religious people are
the most obvious hypocrites around
because we do sometimes spout purity or
morality
but practice prejudice violence abuse
and dishonesty and Jesus is so much as
mad at the Pharisees and the scribes not
because they're good Jews he was a good
Jew and not because they were careful
about their religious practice because
he himself was very careful about his
religious practice he's mad at them
because they're hypocrites they lifted
up their own oral traditions about
ritual purity over the as he sees it
original moral social intent of God's
law somehow they could take up good
principles like Sabbath observance and
by being so focused on extending
holiness to its utmost come around to
contradict the original moral meaning of
the law they could take a principal
intended to enrich human life and
somehow make it destructive of human
life sound like politics or religion in
America's day take a good principle and
somehow twisted around to make it
destructive this was not an argument
unique to Jesus the Pharisees themselves
were vehemently debating these issues
Jesus was not condemning their beliefs
or Judaism he was mad because he saw a
political and religious system that was
chewing up the poor in the name of
holiness the lesson in all our
scriptures today is not however to go
out celebrating the fact that we are
virtuous and those people we know who
they are are hypocrites though that
would be fun let's set aside one Sunday
year when we think about how wonderful
we are and about how awful those people
are get out of our systems maybe one
Sunday we'd be much better off the other
51
I think the bad news of our scripture
today is that we are not Jesus in this
story we are the Pharisees we think we
are moral and those who disagree with us
often are degenerates heartless and
without principles admit it driving down
the road you've thought that about
somebody when we cheat or lie it's just
a simple mistake but when they do it's a
character flaw it's the Mark of Cain we
measure faith with scorecards imagining
that if I carried the biggest Bible and
memorize the most versus I must be
closer to Jesus we are jealous petty
selfish and self deceiving hypocrites as
my grandmother would say we are so cool
and controlled that butter wouldn't melt
in our mouth I always love that phrase
okay have you had enough can i say more
bad things about us I know some of you
would like lent year round so I just
want to make you happy on the other hand
the good news is that Jesus would not be
saying all this if he did not think that
the Pharisees could change we can give
up our religious scorekeeping we can
give up rejoicing in the sins of others
and spend some quality time with our own
sins the good news is that the bad
things we do and even the hypocrisy we
hide behind are forgiven people are
drawn to Jesus because he's honest
because he has a peaceful spirit because
he has compassion in God's name for the
weakest he is the just and beautiful law
that God made human in a place like Yale
which is built on competition and
comparing with each other on hard work
and on doing well I wonder if Jesus
wouldn't say to us to all the Christians
in this place give up
God won't love you anymore if you
succeed or love you any less if you fail
you're struggling to prove yourself will
just get you into trouble it will make
you think you're perfect or perfectible
and you're not I can say because I've
been there that we will you will start
lying to cover up your mistakes and we
all know where that leads I think if we
want to be good people Christians have
two options to deceive ourselves about
how good we are or two to admit that we
are sinners and accept forgiveness
that's about it the hardest part for
many of us is admitting that we sin we
hate giving up control and defining over
defining ourselves oh it's getting
louder but there's real freedom and
coming to the Jordan to be baptized not
to pathologically hate ourselves but
just to be honest you've heard me tell
the story of my friend who didn't
believe in original sin until she had a
child she had a baby and she said that
after she washed her child go through
the stage for about a year when
everything was no and then the stage for
about a year when everything was mine
and finally when the preschool teacher
had her secretly watched her child in
the classroom grabbing toys from other
and whacking them with the toys and then
serenely denying it when the she was
confronted she concluded that becoming a
human individual is training in sin not
willful evil sin but sin built so deep
into us that we have trouble seeing it
in ourselves pride selfishness
self-righteousness prejudice even
cruelty God sees us like that loving
mother hiding in the nursery school
classroom as wayward selfish maybe even
wrong but not evil not to be rejected
sinful but bad but not bad my favorite
source father John Shea tells a
wonderful story with which I will
conclude
he says that every night growing up when
his father came home from work he would
do exactly the same routine father Shea
says he was 6 and every night he watched
this routine he could hear his father
coming up the stairs before he saw him
and when his father came in the door he
would be there he would Pat his head and
take off his hat and plop it on his sons
six-year-old head he says my father was
a policeman and he carried a gun on a
holster on his hip and he would follow
his father down the hall with the
policeman's cap coming down over his
eyes and his ears and his father would
going to the bedroom and in the closet
there was a shelf and there was a wooden
safe there that his father had had
custom-made and on the shelf next to the
safe was the key so with his back to me
my father would open the door he would
take the key off the shelf and open the
safe then he would take off his belt and
holster and take the gun out of the
holster and the holster in the belt were
put in the safe then he would open the
gun and he would take the bullets out
into his free hand he would put the
bullets inside a china dish in the safe
and he would put the gun in the safe and
the bullets and lock it put the key on
the shelf said he would do this every
night as I watched one night he said his
father put the bullets in the dish and
he turned and walked over to me and he
was holding his gun by the barrel and
without saying anything he offered it to
me with this with a smile and he says I
took it and it was incredibly heavy I
couldn't even hold it up and my father
took it back and open the cylinder and
said this is where the bullets go and
his father paused and said do you want
to play with it father Shea says I
nodded and he gave me the gun and he
said don't pull the trigger so John says
I went to the window and I pointed the
gun at the apartment across next door I
looked at my father and he was watching
me but he didn't say anything so I went
over to the bed and I hid behind it and
I popped
up and I aimed my gun but my father
didn't say anything I put the gun in my
pocket like the men I'd seen in the
western movies and I pulled it out fast
draw but my father didn't say anything
so put the gun in my belt and pulled it
out even faster draw but my father
didn't say anything and I lay it on the
floor and took aim and made gunshot
sounds with my mouth and my father
finally said are you done and I nodded
and handed him back the gun and my
father and he said his father turned and
went to the safe and as he had his back
to me locking the gun away he said there
now you won't have to be figuring out
how to get it all the time che says his
words done me not because they were
critical or unkind they were not there
was no judgment involved there was
something more shocking than judgment
there was truth he was right I had been
figuring out how to get it for months
but I wasn't even aware of it I didn't
know I was doing it but I was planning
that day when my parents would be gone
and I could get in there and get at that
gun my father knew me he says before I
knew myself and he gently but truthfully
showed me what I wanted the good news is
that God knows us better than we know
ourselves before our selfish desires
have turned into destructive deeds Jesus
wants to gently show us ourselves
forgiving hypocrites loved sinners and
that is how we are invited to Christ
table stripped of our pretensions free
finally to be who we are not needing to
impress anyone not even our own egos
we come to receive Christ love Christ
self Christ gentle joy Christ limitless
forgiveness amen